these military drills are supposed to
look as realistic as possible NATO's
soldiers pumped up on adrenaline
defending their territory against
unidentified attackers in a large-scale
exercise in northwestern Poland NATO's
new Rapid Response Force showcased its
abilities with live firepower nato
secretary general yang strattenburg said
the troop unit was a necessary reaction
to the conflict in Ukraine despite
opposition by Russia the important thing
is that NATO is increasing its readiness
and it's preparedness and that we are
able also the future to protect and
defend all allies 2,100 soldiers from
nine NATO states took part in the drill
the aim to react to global crises more
quickly and efficiently german defence
minister ors laFonda lion was on hand to
watch the exercises joining her polish
dutch and norwegian counterparts her
position is clear Berlin fully supports
a strong NATO presence in Eastern Europe
assist ina Unga mesna it's an
appropriate defensive measure because
it's important to all of us that we
reassure the Baltic States Poland and
Bulgaria that their concerns are also
our concerns yellows Alfonso's all goes
in Thunder lion also signaled support
for us plans to deploy heavy weapons to
its NATO allies in Eastern Europe NATO
secretary-general Stoltenberg underlined
here in Poland NATO will continue to
strike for dialogue with Russia but
nevertheless the reinforcement of NATO's
high readiness level is the biggest
after Cold War and shows how military
competition has overtaken diplomacy in
east-west relations